[Applaudissements]
il me fait honte
pense que tu dois lui donner une pension
alimentaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très bien
mais au niveau du cardio tu es comment
ça va
vraiment je suis très content
en France à Paris ou à Marseille j'adore
Marseille ça fait mobile je serai là à
part ce dernier mais je l'ai vu à la
télé
aussi vous avez 27 victoires 18 avant la
limite c'est-à-dire que vous mettez KO
tous vos adversaires c'est le coiffeur
qui t'a mis
c'est une envie de comment ça se passe
dans la tête une envie de les défoncer
comment vous faites c'est hyper
impressionnant 18 sur 27 quoi en fait
déjà pour gagner après ça arrive avec
avec voilà avec eux
[Applaudissements]
mais il a peur il a peur il a un peu
court
ce que ça donne
et après on fera Kelly Béatrice dans la
boue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais plus quoi faire de toi
vous vous souvenez que vous vouliez
faire des combats
nous contre quotidien